welcome to google cloud drawing board
where we doodle our way through the
cloud
today's topic what is cloud load
balancing
this video is divided into chapters
watch the full video or skip ahead to
any section of your choice
sam's new application has been a hit
users
are growing across the world but sam is
worried
how would she scale optimize and secure
the app while keeping the users happy
that's where cloud load balancing comes
in it is a fully distributed software
defined solution
that balances user traffic to multiple
backends
to avoid congestion and ensure low
latency there are different types of
load balancing depending on the type of
traffic you are dealing with
global or regional let's understand
these options with a use case
say you have user shen in california you
deploy your backend instances
in that region and configure a load
balancing virtual ip
when your users grow to another region
all you need to do
is to create instances in the additional
regions there's no
change in the virtual ip or the dns
service settings
as your app grows global the same
pattern can follow
you see that maya from india is routed
to the instances in india
now if the instances in india are
overloaded and
are auto scaling to handle the load that
user
will seamlessly be redirected to the
other instance in the meantime
and route back to india when instances
have scaled sufficiently to handle that
load
we just saw that cloud load balancing
uses anycast virtual ips giving you
a single global front-end virtual ip
address
it also provides cross-regional failover
fast auto scaling
and scales to millions of queries per
second
that is external load balancing at layer
7
but in any 3-tier app after the front
end you have
the middleware and the data sources to
interact with in order to fulfill a
user's request
that's where you need layer 4 internal
load balancing
between the front end and the other
internal tiers
layer 4 internal load balancing is
really for tcp
udp traffic behind rfc 1918 whip
where the client ip is preserved you get
the automatic health checks
and there's really no middle proxy it
leverages the software defined
networking controls and data plane for
load balancing
now let's see how the data model for
cloud load balancing actually works
for global https load balancing you have
the global anycast virtual ips
ipv4 or ipv6 associated with the
forwarding rule
which directs traffic to a target proxy
the target proxy terminates the client
session
and for https you deploy your
certificates here
this is not a single device but
distributed logic
throughout the infrastructure the url
map configured provides
layer 7 routing and directs the client
request to the appropriate back-end
service
the back-end services can be managed
instance groups or
network endpoint groups for your
containerized workloads this is
also where service capacity and health
is determined
and cloud cdn is enabled to cache
content for improved performance
you can set up firewall rules to control
traffic to and from your back in here
internal load balancing setup works the
same way
we still have a forwarding rule but here
it points
directly to a back-end service the
forwarding rule has the virtual ip
address
protocol and up to five ports now
security as a best practice we encourage
you to run
ssl everywhere with https and ssl proxy
load balancing
you can use google managed certs where
google takes care of the provisioning
and managing the ssl certificate
lifecycle for you
and cloud load balancing supports
multiple ssl certificates as well if you
wanted to serve multiple domains
using the same load balancing ip address
and port
global load balancing absorbs and
dissipates layer 3
for volumetric attacks across google's
global load balancing infrastructure
additionally by using cloud armor you
can protect against layer 3 to 7
application level attacks and by using
identity of our proxy and firewalls you
can authenticate and authorize
access to your backends now how to
choose the right load balancing option
for deciding which load balancing option
is right for you
consider factors such as internal versus
external
global versus regional type of traffic
https tls udp and based on these factors
decide which one is right for you if you
are looking to reduce latency
improve performance security and
optimize cost for your backend systems
then check out cloud load balancing it
is easy to deploy in just a few clicks
set up the front end and back-ends
associated with the global whips
and you're good to go want to learn more
check out cloud.google.com
load balancing